[Musique]
et c'est la dernière ligne droite avant
le premier tour bonjour valérie pécresse
nos jours comment faites-vous venir ou
revenir des électeurs de la droite et du
centre avec quels arguments on va y
revenir d'abord mêlée pécresse est ce
que vous êtes totalement remise du coc
vide absolument oui mais ça m'a privé de
presque une semaine de campagne à un
moment stratégique
donc effectivement ça n'était pas ce
n'était pas confortable voilà non je les
ai pas dit mais c'est évident vous êtes
candidate à la présidentielle d'ailleurs
un mot parce que le coc vie de revient
en force il ya presque deux cents mille
cas un petit peu moins hier mais par
jour depuis quelques jours est ce que
c'est une menace pour la participation
on avait un peu oublié mais est ce que
ça peut perturber
écouter les français j'espère que non
parce que je souhaite que le maximum de
français puissent s'exprimer c'est le
destin de la france qui se joue en avril
et donc je souhaite que tous aillent
voter avec notamment la confirmation
hier par gabriela talent que les
personnes positives pouvait aller voter
c'est le conseil constitutionnel qu'il
avait de toute façon
formulée mais il faudra faire attention
gestes-barrières je suis bien placé pour
en parler loin et mettre le masque donc
on verra si ça a un impact sur la
participation l'actualité valérie
pécresse avant dormir votre programme
c'est la ferme à qinze est le
gouvernement hier s'est engagée à faire
toute la transparence sur le recours au
cabinet de conseil on rappelle que la
facture ça a été précisé par les
ministres pour 2021 atteint 893 millions
d'euros je crois de mémoire il précise
que cette pratique remonte aux années
2000 en particulier entre 2007 et 2012 à
bord vous présidente est-ce que vous
cesser tout recours à ce type de
conseils et de cabinet de conseil mais
moi par par définition moi je ne suis
pas contre qu'on puisse avoir des
partenariats entre le public et le privé
le sujet qui choque les français c'est
de voir que mc kinsey n'a pas payé ses
impôts en france depuis dix ans et que
l'associé gérant qui est allé au sénat a
vraisemblablement fait les fausses
déclarations sur serment en disant qu'il
payait ses impôts ses impôts en france
d'ailleurs le sénat a lancé une plainte
là dessus donc est ce que c'est normal
d'avoir autant de marchés publics
qu'elle marchait pour faire quoi alors
qu'on ne paye pas ses impôts en france
vous savez moi je veux mettre en place
un ministre spécifique auprès du lycée
finances sur les fraudes fiscales mais
les fraudes sociales parce que je pense
que la fraude c'est du vol et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les français ont besoin
de récupérer cet argent donc xavier
bertrand il ya une semaine sur france
info chez nos confrères s'était engagé à
ce que vous
valérie pécresse vous cessiez tout
contrat avec les cabinets de conseil
vous nuancer ce matin c'est pas si
simple ça dépendra ça dépendra pour
quelles missions mais bien évidemment
pas assez au niveau de mon temps
d'accord donc vous ne l'excusé pas et
d'ailleurs hier les deux ministres ont
rappelé en même souligné que ces
cabinets de conseil avait été très actif
auprès des gouvernements entre 2007 et
2011 notamment pour mener la réforme des
universités donc c'est une pratique
alors ministre vous avez d'abord si ces
données sont totalement contradictoires
avec celles tuerie est donné au sénat
puisque le sénat avait demandé à avoir
toutes les données sur les recours au
cabinet de conseil et l'état lui a
répondu qu'il n'avait aucune donnée
fiable sur ces recours remontant à avant
2018 donc on a dit au sénat qu'il n'y
avait pas de données est aujourd'hui
évidemment on accuse le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy c'est évidemment une
manoeuvre de diversion moi j'ai eu
recours effectivement en 2008 une fois à
un cabinet de conseil pour la
réorganisation du ministère pas du tout
pour la réforme des universités la
réforme des universités c'est moi qu'il
est mené en concertation avec les
partenaires vous ne parleriez pas pour
finir sur ce sujet contrairement par
exemple à xavier bertrand qui avait été
très offensifs on ne riait pas de
scandale d'état et à 10,7 un scandale
d'état ce qui est étonnant c'est que le
gouvernement semble dans cette affaire
avoir quelque chose à cacher on a
l'impression que ça n'est pas
transparent et le sénat a l'air de dire
qu'effectivement il y à des zones dont
moi j'attends la transparence sur cette
affaire ce qui m'a choqué c'est surtout
de voir que bien et manière qu'on n'a
pas réformé l'état pendant son
quinquennat il n'a pas diminué la
dépense publique de nos contraire il a
augmenté il s'était engagé à supprimer
un certain nombre de fonctionnaires à
rendre l'argent aux français il a fait
tout l'inversé il a laissé créé et des
dizaines des centaines de milliers de
passe donc on a augmenté la voilure de
l'état et en même temps on a dépensé des
milliards d'euros avec des cabinets
privés donc on a doublement dépenser le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que nous
avons une dette qui demi milliard
d'euros supplémentaire par rapport à il
ya dix ans et que cette dette et bien
c'est celle des générations futures et
qu'il faudra la rembourser et moi je
m'engage justement à ce que l'on mette
en place une trajectoire pour réduire
cette dette parce qu'il ya dix ans
françois fillon disait que l'état était
en faillite et que aujourd'hui on a
besoin vous savez mais n'en a pas
transmis sa trajectoire budgétaire à
bruxelles ils n'assurent pas d'orage ha
je crains mais je crains qu'il y ait une
addition cachée de ce qu'a d'ailleurs
mais sur ce dossier mckinsey vous nous
dites ça peut être utile de faire appel
à ces cabinets de conseils je les fais
et peut-être que je le referais dit pas
ce matin je coupe mes par ailleurs par
exemple quand vous attribuer un marché
public à une société privée est ce que
vous exigez immédiatement d'avoir des
preuves de sa vertu fiscal il faut bien
évidemment poggia évidemment c'est la
première c'est la première chose qu'il
faut faire et la deuxième je le ferai
oui bien sûr elle a joué avec existe il
y aura un ministre de la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et sociale qui utilisera
désormais un certain nombre d'outils non
mon intelligence artificielle et les
algorithmes pour pouvoir vérifier que
les déclarations sont vrais et j'ajoute
que je réduirai bien évidemment le
recours à ces cabinets de conseil parce
qu'on a des corps d'inspection qui
emmanuel macron veut détruire et en qui
j'aurai confiance et à qui je confierai
démission dans la nuit ce rachat peut
être un sparadrap pour le candidat
macron zèle sparadrap cette éthique du
du papier du canard enchaîné hier à
propos de cette affaire c'est à dire
quelque chose qui va le poursuivre
jusqu'à la fin de la campagne et qui
peut abîmer sa candidature moi ce que je
crois c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
nous engager à faire un certain nombre
de réformes pour lui est ce que ça peut
être politiquement pour vous est-ce que
ça peut abîmer sa candidature tel que
vous le sentez dès qu' il y a le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron n'est pas
transparent des cas le sentiment que il
ya un agenda caché que ce soit financier
que ce soit politique évidemment ça peut
ça peut gêner la candidature et je crois
que vous voyez emmanuel macron a annoncé
qu'il avait moins de 15 ministres avec
plus aucun secrétaire d'état et que des
hauts commissaires ça veut dire que
désormais le gouvernement ne rendra plus
de comptes au parlement puisque c'est
l'ennemi ce qu'ils vont rendre des
comptes au parlement à paléo commissaire
donc vous voyez on a l'impression
aujourd'hui d'une technostructure nous
met présidence qui reprend le contrôle
de il a parlé de la même façon et d'un
parlement fort est ce que vous continuez
à dire qu'il a comme un qu'il a copié
votre programme moi ce que j'ai dit
c'est que il y à un fossé entre le
projet d' emmanuel macron ya un fossé
sur l'autorité parce qu'il est dans le
déni des problèmes de violence des
problèmes d'immigration des problèmes
d'islamisme donc il ya un fossé sur tous
ces sujets régaliens et puis sur le
sujet des réformes il a essayé de
plagier un certain nombre de mes
réformes mais c'est du maquereau c'est à
dire que dès qu'ils commencent à copier
très vite il recule je prends un exemple
la réforme des retraites il dit je vais
faire la réforme des retraites à 65 ans
qui ce que je propose je le propose
pourquoi parce que je veux être la
candidate du pouvoir d'achat et je ne
veux plus coquins retraité qui a une
carrière complète par dix ans vous avoir
au moins le smic net et je veux aussi
l'indexation automatique des retraites
dès qu'il ya 2% d'inflation et je veux
un minimum vous traite à 1000 euros et
je veux protéger les pensions des veuves
les mettre à 75% donc tout ça tout ça ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que il va
sur une réforme de droite mais une
semaine plus tard il dit ce ne sera pas
la priorité de mon quinquennat c'est pas
la réforme priori non mais vous vous dès
qu'il avance lui le recul moi je ne peux
pas faire confiance un président qui est
un président du zigzag il a été le
président de gilles zag sur l'énergie il
a été le président d'ig mag sur
l'agriculture avec le projet de la ferme
où il a accepté la décroissance agricole
1 pécresse donc on a eu un peu endormi
ville je ne crois pas qu'il fera à ses
réformes et je ne crois pas qu'il aurait
le courage de les faire quel est votre
adversaire parce que vous cibler
prioritairement emmanuel macron mais
vous vos concurrents c'est ce sont eric
zemmour et marine le pen qui sont devant
vous dans les sondages je mets à part
jean luc mélenchon vous passez pas tout
à fait sur le même terrain électoral non
je crois qu'aujourd'hui
mon adversaire c'est le scénario écrit
par le système emmanuel mac on ne veut
pas avoir en face de lui une droite
républicaine forte avec un vrai projet
de rupture qui met en cause son bilan et
qu'ils soient puissamment réformatrice
les intentions du 9 1 salle du lma ne
veut pas il ne veut ils veulent
installer depuis le début c'est pour ça
que j'ai été depuis le début la femme à
abattre et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il a
refusé les débats il a refusé d'envoyer
des ministres débattre avec moi parce
que j'aurai démonter son bilan j'aurais
montré que le bilan ce que ce soit sur
l'école que ce soit sur la santé que ce
soit sur la sécurité est un mauvais
bilan et emmanuel macron n'était pas de
droite alors les musées mais il y avait
usurpé heures et puis il ya des la
droite authentique que je représente la
droite riz plusieurs créateurs c'est qui
macron et eric zemmour qui considèrent
qu'ils sont qui se réclament des idées
de la droite alors que ni l'un ni
l'autre ne feront la droite de droite
que je porte la droite c'est moi la
campagne de la primaire c'était beaucoup
concentrée sur les questions de sécurité
d'immigration sont souvient est-ce que
là vous avez pas fait d'achats et
pouvait rien est ce que justement vous
n'aviez pas perdu un peu de temps par
rapport à une préoccupation qui
effectivement ce moment structure la
campagne mais ces journalistes qui
posaient les questions moi je pense que
je suis aujourd'hui la candidat du
pouvoir d'achat parce que mon programme
est financé tout savoir les salaires des
hausses des salaires trop vieillissant
dès l'été de 10 % de la hausse des
salaires 10% de hausse des salaires sur
le quinquennat 3% dès l'été avec la
suppression de 30 % des cotisations
retraite parce que je lancerai la
réforme des retraites des rtt qui
pourront être transformés en salaire la
défiscalisation totale des heures
supplémentaires et pour les familles
effectivement des allocations florent
dernier c'est une première en france
mais woodward h atteints en finlande
c'est un ensemble ainsi si les
entreprises dont vous dites je pense
mais dans les familles monoparentales
puisque je défiscalisent ray les
précieux alimentaires des femmes seules
qui aujourd'hui reçoivent des achats
alimentaires pour leur envoi % dès l'été
pour tous les salariés et puis à charge
pour les entreprises de compléter
jusqu'à 10% sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat avec un donnant-donnant
baisse des impôts de production pour ces
entreprises 10 milliards lui compétitif
10 milliards si elles ne le font pas si
elles ne le font pas c'est quand même
une question c'était une de votre
première proposition les salaires 10% si
elles peuvent pas si elles ne peuvent
pas si elle ne le veulent pas comment
vous les l'obligé comment finalement
vous vous permettez aux français alors
c'est 10 % ont fait une conférence
salariale tous les ans et on fait des
donnant-donnant vous savez que moi ce
que je veux c'est à dire je veux un choc
de simplification je veux diviser par
deux la durée des procédures
administratives c'est très important
présentement nous l'imposent ça va juste
cette question c'est ça je ne suis pas
que ministre je n'impose pas je négocie
et si les entreprises ne le veulent pas
c'est l'état qui olivères des baisses
d'impôts de production fera des baisses
de charges pour les salariés de valdi
aux entreprises on vous enlève aux
baisses de production non non on fera un
donnant-donnant je vous mettrai en place
des conditions de concurrence et de
compétitivité qui seront beaucoup plus
favorables et je compte sur vous pour
augmenter les salaires en redire quand
même assez ya quand même un risque au
final que certaines entreprises ne le
fasse pas écouté aujourd'hui on a 3 %
sur en juin ça veut dire que pour
quelqu'un qui gagne 1400 euros avec moi
il aura 500 euros de plus sur l'année et
j'ai engagé le dialogue avec les
entreprises elle s'engage globalement au
national a augmenté les salaires de 2%
l'année prochaine donc on est déjà pour
2023 pratiquement à 5% de hausse des
salaires et il faut aussi garantir le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités c'est pour
ça que je veux une indexation
automatique dès que l'inflation arrive à
2% pour les retraités une question vous
avez vous dit
et c'est pas comme faut vous rigueur
budgétaire sans doute de sérieuses fois
plus service à d'austérité surtout pas
ce mot deux fois plus d'économies que de
dépenses
84 milliards d'économies 42 milliards de
dépenses est ce que la guerre en ukraine
ne rend pas obsolète à vous comme aux
autres mais c'est vous qui êtes là ne
rend pas obsolète votre trajectoire on
sait déjà par exemple la banque de
france vient en 2023 y aura sans doute
plus qu'un petit pour cent de croissance
est beaucoup moins de près vous allez
faire est ce que je veux que vous êtes
sérieuse ce que je veux moi s'est
décentralisé et je veux supprimer les
doublons aujourd'hui tout le monde fait
tout à tous les étages donc je veux des
blocs de compétences je veux supprimer
les doublons c'est ce que j'ai fait dans
ma région et ça n'est pas récessif c'est
juste mieux utiliser l'argent des
français est le leur rendre dans ma
région je les fais et ça n'a absolument
pas tout à fait ma question je vous
demande s'il allait réviser votre
trajectoire budgétaire continue du fait
que les choix économiques ne sont pas
celles qu'on croyait je vous dis mais je
vous dis que je veux quand même mieux
dépenser l'argent des français les
français ont le droit qu'on dépense
mieux ils ont le droit de pas avoir 2000
guichets des aides aux entreprises
différents donc voilà regret l'acfo
sommes frais vous ne bougerait pas ce
que je veux adapterez pas ma ma
trajectoire c'est une trajectoire qui
est vertueuse donc je la tiendrais je
continuerai les réformes mais ce que je
ferai c'est que je ferai une politique
très forte de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
des ménages ceux qui bénéficient du rsa
fameuse proposition du rsa conditionné
je rends 25 centimes sur les prix de
l'essence parce que l'état semble avoir
gagné 25 centimes en hausse de taxes et
ne rentrent que 18 sont ils vous dites
c'est passé 18 centimes soit 25 centimes
et vous dites semble parce qu'on n'est
pas sûr effectivement de ce que ça
rapporte vraiment la hauteur il y ait
transparence sûr sûr sûr tout cela
j'avais demandé la transparence elle n'a
pas été fait c'est pas évident la
transparence cela dit parce que
l'essence coûte plus cher mais les
français s'est documenté en achètent
moins et le temps qu'on est les
additions et soustractions en temps réel
c'est pas facile oui enfin c'est surtout
baissé sur le passé que je demande ceux
qui bénéficient du rsa donnant chaque
semaine 15 heures d'activités formation
emploi ou travaux d'intérêt général
obligatoires ouiya toit des emplois
publics éventuellement d emplois
annoncées les départements qui auront la
charge d'amener les bénéficiaires du rsa
vers un chemin d'emplois donc c'est des
emplois de réinsertion qui sont adaptés
à la personne et à ses capacités à
reprendre un emploi ce sont des
personnes qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi mais dans revenus une
solidarité qui via active donc il faut
les ramener vers l'emploi et c'est
normal de demander une contrepartie au
rsa là encore emmanuel macron a plagié
la mesure mais quelques jours plus tard
il a dit oui mais avec moi ce ne sera
pas obligatoire donc vous voyez il faut
c'est de la fausse monnaie moi j'ai un
vrai programme qui reprendra certains
nombres un certain nombre d idées de la
droite républicaine et je veux les
portes et je veux les ports des ja et or
mais palop a pour tous ne peuvent pas il
a qui sont tellement éloignés et les
personnes qui sont malades étaient à ce
moment-là les des personnages qui
pourront pas à la maintenance est ici
cette question des mères seules n'est
pas la bonne aujourd'hui nous devons
aider ces mères seules d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça aussi que je donne les
allocation dès le premier enfant des
questions familiales dès le premier
enfant au contraire on doit aider ces
personnes faire garder leurs enfants
pour qu'elle retrouve le chemin de
l'emploi les amis vers mayala vierzon il
enfermé à la maison avec un rsa c'est au
contraire les condamnés à la pauvreté et
les condamnés à ne pas pouvoir reprendre
le chemin de l'emploi elles ont besoin
donc celle en bronze un mauvais service
est ce que vous créerez qui est un
propos un ministère plein de la famille
comme eric zemmour non moi je souhaite
je souhaite aujourd'hui avoir un très
grand ministère des affaires sociales et
qui s'occupera aussi de la famille et du
handicap alors lui vous vous rappelez il
veut favoriser l'instabilité dans la
ruralité en versant une prime de 10
mille euros la naissance de chaque
enfant dans la famille et demi il y est
depuis deux ans dans un territoire rural
bonne idée et moi je veux favoriser la
même des idées le film non je veux
favoriser la natalité en france
aujourd'hui nous avons 10% de naissance
ans - il les familles et des familles et
les familles souffrent justement de mal
logement on n'a pas du tout parlé du
logement dans cette campagne il a parlé
de pouvoir d'achat dans mon projet il ya
la création et la rénovation de 500
mille logements pour les familles cent
cinquante mille logements sociaux mais
aussi la possibilité de devenir
propriétaire avec un prêt à taux zéro
sur toute la france et sur la question
des familles je le dis ce qui est très
important c'est que toutes les familles
puissent être aidés dès le premier
enfant et c'est mon projet avec 900
euros voilà rend jusqu'à la majorité
j'ajoute que dans la grisaille euros on
va souvent accouché dans l'hôpital qui
est dans une ville donc je pense que
cette mesure est une mesure tout à fait
gagnée alors question je vous demande
une réponse brève marine le pen
réintégrera immédiatement les soignants
suspendu car non vaccinés si elle est
élue et vous
je pense que maintenant si la crise
s'éloigne de toutes les façons il faudra
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinées
dans l'hôpital nous avons aujourd'hui
toujours ceux qui sont pas vaccinés pour
en revenir travailler si la crise est
derrière nous et si aujourd'hui on
considère qu' il n'y a plus de gestes
barrières qu'il n'y a plus de passes
sanitaires je pense qu'il faudra donc
vous ne le ferez pas entrer ce vaccin
par une réforme de lacaune du code de
santé publique dans les vaccinations
obligatoires aujourd'hui auquel on se
leva le vaccin qu'ovide n'est pas un
vaccin obligatoire et aujourd'hui ce que
je veux c'est que dès que les autorités
sanitaires le permettront on revienne à
une situation normale vous savez qu'on a
perdu aujourd'hui à l'hôpital 10 % des
lits donc il va falloir faire un grand
plan de retour des personnels soignant à
l'hôpital tous les personnels soignants
doivent revenir et c'est important dès
que la crise que vit ce sera derrière
nous qu'on puisse faire revenir tous ses
personnels moi je crève et 25 mille
postes à l'hôpital le problème des
postes à l'hôpital c'est non seulement
des problèmes de salaires c'est les
problèmes au site considération et
conditions de vie et je me suis aperçu
quand j j'avais la crise covin dans ma
région que les salles de repos des
soignants était indigne je me suis
aperçu que dans l'hôpital les chefs de
service n'avait pas suffisamment de
pouvoirs dans mon programme pour la
santé on redonne du pouvoir au chef de
service à l'hôpital et on redonne de la
qualité de vie aux soins mme pécresse
j'avais d'ailleurs financé des salles de
repos avec l'association d'anne
roumanoff à l'heure j'étais la femme à
battre rien ne nous a été épargné dans
cette campagne peu importe aujourd'hui
moi ce que je crois c'est que je peux
être la surprise du deuxième tour si les
électeurs de droite veulent un vrai
programme de droite qui ramène l'or dans
la rue et aux frontières qui fort et
puissant contre le totalitarisme
islamiste mais qui est efficace et qui
est républicain et réformateurs parce
que la france a besoin de réformes et
moi je dis aux français on est champion
du monde des impôts mais nos services
publics ne sont pas à la hauteur et puis
diviser les français il l'a il les a
méprisé vallet loire aujourd'hui je veux
les rassembler autant la ruralité que là
je disais rennes nous a été épargné et
je pensais dernièrement au fait que
nicolas sarkozy non plus il a il renonce
à venir à votre meeting dimanche
est ce que ça changerait quelque chose
qui vienne moi j'étais très fier d'être
ministre ni changer quelque chose je
viens vous j'ai beaucoup appris avec lui
mais je pense que les français ils
votent pour une candidate est un projet
pour la france donc ça n'a rien eu de
vote ils ne votent pas pour un comité
est ce que ça aurait changé quelque
chose qui viennent je trace ma route
aujourd'hui dont je ne me pose pas de
questions je ne me pose pas de questions
je les ai invités par déférence parce
que j'invite évidemment une piqûre
tutélaire de notre famille politique
mais aujourd'hui celle qui représente
les idées de la droite c'est moi et
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs ça se bagarre entre cette
famille de droite c'est le patron thème
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la candidate ces
mots et ces mois de films résigné c'est
moi qui ai été désigné par les par les
français est fabula vérité il vous a dit
non oui mais vous savez les français
mangent et les rencontres il me parle de
quoi ils parlent de leur pouvoir d'achat
on parle de la sécurité ils me parlent
de leur vie quotidienne il parle de la
santé la service public à bout de
souffle il me parle de l'école qui n'est
plus une école de l'efs peu de chance
ils me disent il faut reconstruire la
france madame pécresse essaie ça vous
avez à ça que je veux me le disais tout
à l'heure vous avez une concurrente
devant van khê sérieuses et marine le
pen bien une petite musique qui monte
elle ne fait plus peur elle fait une
bonne campagne elle ne fait pas d'erreur
elle peut gagner le 24 avril est ce que
vous êtes d'accord mais je vous lis ça
fait partie du plan d' emmanuel lafont
qui a été de dédiaboliser les extrêmes
pour se retrouver face à eux mais à sa
saison version narration - est-ce
qu'elle sait sur l'assurance victoire se
ressèment la face aux extrêmes dont moi
ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui c'est
montrer que marine le pen c'est madame
150 milliards de dépenses non financées
donc elle peut promettre tout à tout le
monde mais son projet amènera les
français à la discorde et aussi à la
faillite à la faillite et elle peut
gagner
si la démagogie rentrer dans cette
campagne tout est possible moi je veux
un programme sérieux construit la corne
réponses qu'ils apportent des solutions
français et c'est ça que les français
verraient entend bien veulent quelqu'un
devant virèrent mais ma quelqu'un qui
veut plaire on a deux candidats qui
veulent plaire emmanuel macron et marine
le pen moi j'ai dit je fais je dis ce
que je fais avant et je fais après et
j'ai le courage de dire la vérité ils
veulent plaire et daniel venel horaire
il va falloir faire des riffs alors une
question de clarification d'un décret si
elle est au 2e tour face à un adversaire
et qui n'est pas vous est ce que vous
pourriez voter pour elle madame
martichoux je viens de vous dire je veux
être la surprise de ce deuxième tour
donc je vais me valérie pécresse vous
êtes jeannerat kien si j'en ai posé la
question à l'époque à jacques chirac la
réponse auraient fusé est ce que vous
pourriez noté norman manley martichoux
que ce soit jacques chirac où que ce
soit nicolas sarkozy jamais un candidat
à la présidentielle ne se projette dans
un deuxième tour en se disant qu'il n'y
sera pas moi j'y serai j'y serai parce
que les français savent où réside sa
nouvelle et francisation n'hésitant les
français sont hésitants et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les sondages ne veulent rien
dire parce que les français sont libres
et ils peuvent voter qu'ils veulent
dimanche 10 avril et ce jour là moi je
les appelle à voter pour une droite
sincère une droite qui ne ment pas une
droite qui n'est pas
aït mais c'est une question et une
droite qui va faire des réformes
pakalitha une droite qui débauche et qui
recopient et qui plagie mal pardon mais
certains parents vous entendant peuvent
se dire
ça veut dire que c'est pas exclu mais
madame martichoux je sais prendre mes
responsabilités quand il le faut mais
aujourd'hui la situation n'est pas du
tout celle là la situation aujourd'hui
c'est celle d'une candidate qui a été
empêchée de faire campagne pendant une
semaine par l'aco vide et qui
aujourd'hui revient sur le devant de la
scène pour dire si vous voulez vraiment
des solutions et si vous voulez et lien
qui va mettre en oeuvre un vrai projet
pour la france pour dernière gëstu
donner du pouvoir d'achat et la sécurité
il faut voter pour valérie pécresse
comme vous avez été élue la primaire
vous êtes venu devant les militants dire
vous avez l'audace de désigner une femme
qui pourrait être prêt dans la
république c'est une carte sur laquelle
vous jouez peu et pourtant moi ce que je
veux c'est que ça change les choses pour
les femmes de mes dires c'est pour ça
que j'ai proposé une justice
spécialisées pour juger enfin les
violences intrafamiliales dans les 72
heures c'est pour ça que je m'occupe des
femmes des familles monoparentales et de
leurs deals à défiscaliser leur
prestation faire voter pour nous ça
c'est pour ça que je fais de la santé
des femmes de la santé les bras devant
un grande cause du week-end à bas
écouter et que je m'occupe des farcis et
de la conciliation la vie familiale et
professionnelle 6 mai être une femme
n'est pas en soi une seule la seule
qualité mais si on met lit ça changera
quelque chose pour toutes les femmes de
france et pour leur conciliation de leur
vie professionnelle et femmes il s'est
dit merci valérie pécresse d'avoir été
ce matin